the traditional media traffic has
absolutely plummeted it's fallen off a
cliff the traditional media companies
they are dying people don't care anymore
well don't take my word for it here is
the data the traffic to the actual
websites the new york times is down 34
year-over-year the washington post is
almost down half it's down 44
but it's not just print whether it's
digital or physical newspapers it's also
the television as well network
television seeing a massive decrease cnn
down 38 fox down 34
msnbc down 25
these numbers are astonishing to most
people
there are multiple reasons why this is
occurring one of the best reasons is
because people are losing trust in the
institutions they obviously don't
believe that the new york times or the
washington post cnn fox and msnbc are
telling them the truth if you think that
you're being lied to if you think that
there's manipulation of the facts or the
information if you think that people are
simply regurgitating information in a
perspective to get you to believe
something to enhance the division in our
country you simply can turn off the
television or you can stop clicking on
the articles and obviously that is one
piece of what is happening here on top
of that for the last 18 months or so
there has been absolute hysteria both
economically and from a public health
perspective obviously there was tons and
tons of people who kept turning to the
news whether it was network television
or the papers and saying what the hell
is going on in the world when it comes
to the virus or the economic impact of
it if you remember cnn literally had a
death scoreboard on their television
show every day 24 7. you turn it on and
they told you look what the score is
look at how many people have died so far
and they not only did it here in the
united states they did it globally as
well it was depressing every time i
would see it i would want to shut it off
because who the hell wants to see that
every single day on top of that also we
are coming off the presidency of donald
trump and if you go back to 2016 donald
trump had said the news media will die
if i'm not around i'm paraphrasing but
ultimately that is part of this as well
is that they knew every time that they
put his name in a headline those
articles or they talked about them on a
television segment those segments became
more popular whether that's good or bad
he understood that and the media
understood that there was a game going
on and so the media kept talking about
him he kept doing stuff to get them to
talk about him so ultimately the traffic
had surged so whether you believe that
there's a loss of trust in the
institutions whether you believe that
the coveted economic stuff ends up now
people aren't as interested or you
believe it has to do with a precedent
that is not nearly as kind of headline
driven the traffic is down and
ultimately what i think this tells us is
two things one this is an opening for
other types of media outlets whether
they are people like joe rogan or other
types of actual media companies to come
forward and take some of this market
share but also too is that they are
becoming more desperate and when media
companies become desperate they then
start to concoct all kinds of crazy
ideas they can create all sorts of
division in the society in order to get
people to pay attention they can create
narratives that take hold to get people
to click or to watch
and also they start to tell you crazy
crazy things like if you don't do what
we tell you you will die which quite
literally is what was being told to us
all year last year and so i think that
this data is not only important to
understand but to unpack why it's
happening and when you start to
understand why it's happening you start
to see that the long-term trend is that
the mainstream media is losing power
they're losing a voice and ultimately
people are starting to realize rather
than listen to the talking heads on
mainstream media maybe what i should be
doing is going and finding the market
participants maybe i should be finding
the source information maybe i should
stop listening to what they have to say
because obviously they are biased but at
a minimum if i'm going to listen to what
let's say fox news says maybe i should
actually pay attention to what cnn and
msnbc says you're going to get biased
news get biased news from all corners so
that you can have a more well-rounded
perspective and try to figure it out for
yourself my only message to people is
defund the media the way to defund the
media stop clicking stop watching and
literally start learning for yourself
now it's hard to do that and so
ultimately you can either go find
independent sources of information or
you can simply consume it and then say
i'm going to focus in 2022 i'm thinking
for myself what do you guys think in
terms of seeing i mean these aren't like
hey the traffic's down five percent
we're talking about
25 to 44
across these different mediums that's
big numbers massive numbers but so i
think about it in the context of a few
different things one i think a lot of
this was due to trump right if you look
up the numbers relative to where they
had been historical they were up a lot
during his presidency he was constantly
providing clippable moments quotable
moments etc where people were uh giving
headlines there was a bunch of clickbait
there was all these things people were
generally interested in he was a very
polarizing president for sure regardless
of which side of the aisle you sat on so
i think that was part of it right if you
set the base so high then ultimately
anything below that you're going to be
down drastically so that's certainly
part of it two i think that certainly
over the last year uh there has been a
rise in independent journalism and
people that are creating content on
their own i know just like i i don't
know the statistics for sure but if you
look at my inbox just the amount of
blogs or sub stacks or uh independent
journalists that are delivering content
daily weekly et cetera the amount that
hits my inbox has drastically gone up
like 10-fold probably from a year or two
ago so that has obviously been a trend
that has accelerated throughout uh this
digital internet age where information
is abundant and then three i think like
part of it is yeah it's just the
pandemic like a lot of this stuff has
been uh has gotten crazy over the past
uh 12 to 24 months and i think a lot of
people have opened their eyes and seen
what is really driving a lot of these
businesses and it is the idea of
creating outrage it is the idea of
clickbait it is uh getting your
attention in whatever way they possibly
can and a lot of that is done through
fear right so when you think about in
that context um i think people over the
last over the last year or two are
getting fed up with it and they're
realizing that a lot of the stuff that
they're being showed either had to twist
to it or is just outright not true and
ultimately it only takes a few of those
times to start changing your sources if
you say hey look i read this article uh
it was extremely deceiving based on the
title and kind of what they were
explaining versus what their the reality
of the situation was if that happens
once okay whatever you know i read the
source all the time not a big deal two
times three times four times five times
you start to get fed up and you start
looking for alternative sources and i
think there has been a huge uh
distinction and importance placed on
first first level sources right the
original source and i think that a lot
of people are opening their eyes to
the context that that provides and
that's why we've seen this continued
shift and ultimately this is only a
trend that's going to continue right
there's more people that are leaving
their jobs every single day and going to
do this independent route and that's
good for a few different things
obviously
it hurts them from a leverage
perspective right you don't have the
whole staff you don't have the resources
that these these places typically
provide but ultimately they're able to
speak more of the truth or their truth
right what they see their world view and
ultimately the the consumers who ends up
deciding if that is true or not right
you get to go decide hey i agree with
this source i don't agree with the
source i don't like the way they
interpreted this i like the way they
interpreted this and ultimately that's
what's going to change things is more
people opting out of that system right
so when you say defund just stop reading
right if you don't agree with uh with a
source or a news corporation or an
outlet stop reading their information go
to other sources there's plenty of them
out there now and i think that that's
what we've seen over the last 12 to 24
months john before we get your
perspective we have one more chart here
uh that shows that online most that turn
to news websites except for the youngest
uh people they're all older folks right
so if you look at this right here on a
percentage basis news websites or apps
32 i think this is pr yeah percent of us
adults who get news often from news
websites and apps it's 65 and older if
you then look at people over the age of
50 right again huge percentages and then
obviously if you look 30 to 49 uh it's
still um you know very much heavily
weighted with news websites or apps what
i find fascinating is between the ages
of 18 to 29 they actually don't get
their
information from news websites or apps
42 of it comes from social media
and so i say fascinating because there's
an argument for that being a good thing
that's argument for that being a bad
thing but the fact that that is such a
big percentage of 18 to 29 year olds i
think is interesting the second thing i
think is interesting is 18 to 29 year
olds they get just as much from news and
websites or apps as they do from search
so there's an equal weighting at 28
right versus if you look at 30 50 and 65
age cohorts basically it's still
weighted much more heavily to the the
news websites versus these other things
and then lastly is podcast so the
younger people listen to podcasts right
12
versus let's say over 65 then listen to
three percent now the podcast could
include news podcasts but they also
could include things like independent uh
information sources etc but when you
start to see that somewhere between the
ages of 18 to 29 is essentially four
times more likely to listen to a podcast
to get their information versus somebody
over the age of 65 i don't think that's
surprising but when you actually see the
numbers and you start to recognize this
it's look the the area where uh
information is coming from the
consumption is changing and ultimately
social media is just a new distribution
platform right the same information like
well guess where all the news uh
websites go and distribute their
information they're trying to go to
email they're trying to go to podcast
they're trying to go to social media et
cetera and so i don't know if
necessarily the information's different
on social media it's just a different
medium and understanding where these
cohorts are consuming their information
is important if you want to continue to
remain relevant and
[Music]
kind of remain in front of the younger
cohorts as they age into you know your
core demographic part of that too makes
me think that it levels the playing
field a little bit right because
traditionally if you were an outlet and
you built up this massive distribution
right you had the capital to go uh
distribute newspapers right on a very
small level and then you built up this
capital to go do these these massive
productions on tv and you're paying for
these slots and everything you had that
distribution that you were paying for
that your capital allocated enabled you
to do that and social media has totally
flipped out on its head right anyone can
start a twitter account anyone can start
an instagram account anyone can start a
youtube channel and sure there are some
advantages that come
with news outlets having that built out
distribution but ultimately we've seen
countless people do it you can start
from xero and build a big account just
based on your beliefs your research your
work ethic and all of that so ultimately
i think social media has played an
important role in the competition of
ideas right in the free market of ideas
and allowing people to debate these
things and obviously uh the truth
doesn't always win out we've seen
various scenarios where people use fear
and other tactics to engage with people
and build followings but ultimately it's
been a good thing from an independent
journalism side because it enables more
people to be involved and it and it
further uh further pushes pushes forward
the competition of ideas in a free
market john what do you think about this
everyone's biased every media company
that you listen to every person on the
internet they're all biased in some some
way shape or form i think that if you
watch fox news for example you should
absolutely turn on cnn
i think it's important to get both sides
of the argument on both sides of
thinking and then you can kind of form
your own opinion because everyone
everybody just spins the story to fit
their narrative and what they want to
say right you see using it countless
times where media companies will go out
and they'll actually fund a survey just
so it fits their narrative right so the
independent um creators i think is
awesome for both social media sub stack
like all the companies that are
capitalizing on this but people are
being able to publish their ideas in a
new way that it traditionally hasn't
been and then when you look at podcasts
i don't really think a lot of people are
getting news from podcasts i think it's
possible within the next 10 15 years but
it has to be timely right that's why i
like twitter so much is because it's
very very timely and um you can kind of
crowdsource a bunch of different ideas
you can like easily find new people um
but yeah it's not surprising at all that
younger people are using social media
rather than watching cnbc or watching
like different uh different news outlets
and if anyone wants a good uh good book
on
media manipulation and all that trust me
i'm lying by ryan hall day is a great
book for that that is a good book